m
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale du climat les élèves des
options de développement durable et
sciences du collège amiral bouvet à
saint benoît ont souhaité faire un bilan
sur tous les projets menés ces dernières
années à travers cette implication je
pense donc donner des citoyens du monde
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important alors dans le collège n'a donc
en 2012 et demi et entre 2012 et 2014
on a eu la première action qui est quand
le collège devient jardin donc s'il
s'agissait de végétaliser la cour du
collège
ensuite nous avons mis en place une
meilleure gestion des déchets au collège
donc en 2014 2015 et non dernier donc
les deux projets phares on m'a mis en
place la collecte du papier dans les
classes donc ça s'est réalisé par les
élèves les éco délégués et les élèves de
l'option développement durable qui
collectent tous les deux mois à peu près
les papiers dans les classes et les
mêmes pour les mêmes dans la poubelle
jaune pour le recyclage
on a aussi fait l'année dernière des
collecte de textiles en partenariat avec
l'association ti temps de la q2 collecte
une collègue pour la semaine de
réduction des déchets au mois de
novembre et une collecte pendant la
semaine du développement durable début
juin pour l'occasion les élèves ont eu
l'honneur de poser la plaque et qu'au
collège à l'entrée de leur établissement
un réel plaisir et une grande fierté de
voir leurs efforts récompensés
le collège amiral bouvet compte cette
année plus de 60 éco-délégués tous très
investi dans l'écologie et le
développement durable
on doit conduire défendre notre planète
qui est vraiment en train de souffrir
le réchauffement climatique heures la
température moyenne de la terre au monde
chaque année
et inquiétante m'intéresse parce que
personne ne respecte pas là et je me dis
que moi moi je respecte et j'aimerais
faire comprendre aux attaques il faut
respecter ça comme ça tu es ma première
année j'avais envie de tester de
nouvelles choses qu'on faisait pas en
primaire et au site où j'ai trouvé ça
bien et surtout qu'on fait des choses
dans le collège paul développement
durable des choses comme ça le conseil
départemental soutient depuis plusieurs
années le collège amiral bouvet dans ses
projets en effet c'est un concours
organisé par la collectivité qui a été
l'élément déclencheur de la mise en
place de ses nombreuses actions
le collège a été un des premiers à avoir
participé au contrôle du plus beau
collège de riz et vous avez entendu que
la principale où la professeur a dit que
c'était le point de départ le déclic
pour mettre en place un certain nombre
d'actions
l'année dernière ils ont été labellisés
et qu'au collège on a un drapeau qui
figurent donc critique qui est justement
sur la devanture
aujourd'hui on assiste à la pose de
plaques puisqu'ils sont labellisés une
deuxième fois et possède deux labels et
bien le département les accompagne à
hauteur de 3000 euros pour le travail
qui aura été accompli
le collège amiral bouvet reçoit donc
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
label international et qu'au collège qui
récompense le projet des élèves
intitulé vers une meilleure gestion des
déchets au collège